[Musique]
dans l'eau
oh
chan
sa guise
c'est ma vie
de plus près
[Musique]
je
c'est pour vous expliquer la vie la vie
passe déjà par la pitié vieillesse au
retour on a commué ensemble est en somme
c'est une superbe 1986 il y avait il y
avait
quand je joue à la suisse pour avoir le
la beneliga mais les anti pays d'où il y
avait aux élèves etienne aussi belle
qu'elle
il ya un moment dans la vie qu'on a
envie de partager j'ai tellement la
musique m'a tellement donné
la musique m'a donné beaucoup d'amis
beaucoup de de connaissances alors je
pense qu'il est grand temps pour moi de
donner moi de redistribuer un peu plus
de bonheur je partage cette amitié avec
des moules avec charles est qu avec
pareil ils ont pas un jeune qui va
interpréter ivan tous interprétés du
team aux trn
mais l'amitié sera au rendez vous parce
que j'ai rencontré des amis dans d'avant
des amis d'enfance les lors de l'eau les
marines les dons dont les gervais bonne
masse tous âgés qu'ailleurs
toute cette grande famille puis une
belle section de cuivres qui seront
toute amitié avec moi pour partager vous
tu sais je vais essayer de faire
rejaillir entre le rayon rayon de
bonheur rien de bonheur à traves c'est
comme un arc-en-ciel le bonheur que je
vais donner demain soir vendredi soir
du sol est passé en dessous
chan
ça q ue
c'est l'avant
[Musique]
est ce plus près
le dernier sac à qui remonte à cinq ans
que les chemins parfois tu me pose des
questions c'est mieux ses yeux jeudi
cinq ans et plus et l atrium ces vieux
j'avais même dit tu sais où blessés bobo
- j'avais même dit que je voulais plus
on monte sur la scène j'étais déçu de ce
spectacle lorsque j'avais fait un
mélange de musique étrangère à la vienne
cette fois ci aura que du timothée rêve
mais ça remonte ça remonte ça remonte
mais ce sera meilleur ce sera meilleur
c'est garanti rembourser si pas garanti
[Rires]
silvère tian
c'est que
[Musique]
là
sanawa navarra
oh
m
au 6 mai
en
oh
votre tir est grand jour votre vie a
changé cette semaine oui oui j'ai repris
l'habitude d'être d'être angoissé
stressé de me lever tôt de ne pas dormir
d'avoir de l'insomnie j'ai pris
l'habitude tout vous d'avoir de l'eau
libre à tout d'abord dans dix roi de la
nuit
bref quoi je parle le rallye beaulieu si
sa pâte à mâcher qu'éloigné pousse à
bourgoin s'est alors ça a beaucoup
changé dans ma vie j'ai retrouvé j'ai
retrouvé j'ai retrouvé des amis aussi
j'ai retrouvé des amis des amis qui
m'ont reproché d'avoir disparu de n'être
pas resté en haut de la fiche fois des
amis qui m'ont dit que tu ne chantes pas
ces deux termes musique de timothée rey
les jeux retrouver ces gens qui m'ont
passé un savon il me passe un savon mais
ils sont toujours là
je vous ai je vous ai tout le temps
[Musique]